so Russia says a civilian evacuation
from Carson in southern Ukraine has
begun the Ukrainian Army says its
counter-offensive has actually slowed
down in recent days Russian forces are
heavily dug in they say but Kiev is
preparing for a renewed push towards
this russian-occupied city Charles
Stratford reports now from the front
line Village of shashankove
is received
they have to move fast
from the cover of trees we follow this
near 60 year old soviet-built grad
rocket launcher to a firing position
incoming Russian shells land to our left
22 year old Ukrainian Soldier Roman
lines up the weapon
tree of firing up positions near kaizan
City they admit that their
counter-offensive has slowed down in
recent days one of the reasons they say
is because the Russians are heavily dug
in in fortified positions
open the boot open the boot
we have to fall back fast
Russian forces can get a fix on a firing
position and respond in around three
minutes
Ukrainian artillery far over our heads
another one
Russian forces respond their shells land
in a field behind
the Ukrainian Commander tells us they
are preparing for an advance on the
Russian occupied city of her son
the Fortified positions that the enemy
have established are concrete and they
have a minimum of three lines of Defense
we are in High Spirits but we are
lacking equipment to move forward so we
are accumulating the hardware from our
International partners then we will
advance because we are trying to protect
our soldiers and they are prepared for
us
the Russian army should not be
underestimated
Roman joined the Ukrainian Army four
years ago a full barrage of the rocket
system he operates lacks Precision but
can cover an area 600 meters square
Russian forces use this weapon too
when I go into fire I keep a positive
mindset and I am not afraid because if
we Panic we will not achieve our aim
the hedgerows and tree lines North of
kirison city are full of Ukrainian
soldiers and artillery positions
the men here say small Russian
reconnaissance teams regularly try and
push forward
they are digging new trenches and are
ever vigilant for Russian drones above
but hardly a night passes without
attacks by Russian missiles or so-called
Kamikaze drones killing or injuring
civilians in the closest Frontline city
of mikolayev
it's a miracle no one was killed when a
Russian Missile hit this flower market
in the center of town
the Russians expect me to hate them for
this but I fight these feelings I don't
want to feel hate I have no desire for
their homes to be destroyed but I want
all who came here and occupied my
country to be killed
a Ukrainian tank heads South towards her
son where an evacuation of civilians is
believed to have begun
Charles Strafford Al Jazeera shiv
shinkovi Sun Ukraine
Al Jazeera is covering this story from
all angles with correspondence on the
ground Muhammad James is in key Muhammad
Val is in Moscow first though let's go
to Charles Stratford he's in kriviri
Charles how close are we to an offensive
against the Strategic city of Curson
it's very difficult to tell but
certainly according to the Ukrainian
soldiers that we spoke to yesterday they
said that they are indeed preparing for
such a push of course this comes on the
back of weeks of a counter-offensive by
Ukrainian forces from the North and the
west of kirison we understand that the
closest Ukrainian forces to that Russian
occupied City are around about 20 to 30
kilometers away as you heard in our
report there they um they're basically
taking their time the commander that we
spoke to said that they are busy trying
to accumulate as much Weaponry as they
can and they are waiting for additional
support from their Western backers that
Western Weaponry that we have seen to be
so important in this counter-offensive
but of course there are huge concerns
for certainly what the Russians are
reporting to be up to 50 60 000
civilians inside kerson City and we've
seen video evidence of an evacuation
possibly already having started from
that City and bear in mind that many of
these civilians will not want to be
evacuated to the Russian side we saw
huge demonstrations by ukrainians when
the Russians occupied that City in the
early stages of the war so we know there
are thousands of ukrainians that will
not want to be taken to Russia whether
we're going to see any kind of organized
Corridor and a cessation of hostilities
to allow ukrainians to move out onto the
Ukrainian side remains to be seen the
big concern is though is how these
civilians if they indeed do want to move
or if they are forcibly moved will get
across that River we know that the
antonovsky bridge the main Bridge across
the the danipa River South has been
compromised heavily damaged we also know
certainly according to the Russian
Commander he said saying that the new
Russian Commander Sergey sorofikin
saying that the large hydroelectric Dam
which is about 50 kilometers up the
river north of Kirsten he's saying that
that has been hit as well obviously this
has huge implications for Supply chains
for Russian troops but also for food and
vital materials for the civilians still
inside kerson as well as potentially
evacuation routes out
all right Charles Stratford thank you to
you and your team for your reporting
thank you very much and stay safe now
let's look at the areas that Russia is
struggling to hold on to its forces have
been driven back up to 30 kilometers
along the nipro river which is a
strategic natural hurdle on this terrain
the Ukrainian Army has destroyed two
major road Bridges across the Waterway
cutting off Russian supply lines and
croissant we've been saying it's key why
well partly because it controls the main
land route to the Crimean Peninsula that
Russia seized back in 2014. all right
Mohammed valve joins us from Moscow
Muhammad I was planning to ask you uh
about the
the the power situation because entire
chunks of the country have just been cut
off from the power grid
right uh Cyril I think you wanted first
to ask me about uh what's happening on
the Russian side and that's uh basically
summarized in the statements by Sergey
sorovicin the new Commander in Chief for
the Russian special operation in eastern
Ukraine Eastern Southern Ukraine he
basically acknowledged for the first
time that Russia is in a difficult
situation I mean the Russian army there
and he said the evacuation of civilians
must happen as soon as possible because
Russia wants to make sure those citizens
are protected and Russia has the ability
to protect them they were provided safe
and free transfer and crossing and
accommodation on the southern side of
the river the junipro river and also
they were urged to even go into Russia
itself if they want the Russians saying
that this is a voluntary transfer if
they don't want to go they they can stay
but they have to take the risks of
staying where they are right now they
are talking about a new push and new
plans by the Ukrainian Army to uh to
attack her son and particularly the
infrastructure
he talked about the dam that you have
just mentioned a little earlier or
Charles has just mentioned that Dam has
been compromised and it might release
what its Hydro power Dam that might
release water and that could cause
floodings that will further jeopardize
the lives of those civilians it's a
tough situation remember that usually in
Russia it's the Minister of Defense the
Minister of Defense who gives statements
of this type or the the the the
commander of chief of all the armored
forces but this man has just been
appointed a couple weeks ago and this is
a precedent that he is giving such a
huge uh statements and remarks about
what's happening and particularly about
the difficulties Russians are facing but
I also said there will be tough choices
to make and tough decisions to take
during the next few days and
understandably you know he's known his
history in Syria he led the operation
there the destruction of Aleppo and so
on and we have seen this increase during
the last few days of those suicide
drones across Ukraine very much a
reminder of of what could happen what
the Russians might do and also a
reminisce reminiscent of what happened
in Syria
the remember the uh the uh the the the
the the the barrel bombs in Syria and so
on so I mean he's he's certainly from
his words between the lines he's
planning something something big but at
first he wants the civilians to be moved
away from that area before the Russians
take a tougher and more drastic measures
there all right Mohammed Val thank you
very much for your reporting from Moscow
thank you for that mistake at the top uh
now let us go to Muhammad James he is
live for us in Kiev and so Muhammad I
was planning to ask you that's what I
was telling Mohammed Val earlier ask you
about the power situation how we're
doing there but I also can't help but
notice that you've put the best the vest
and the helmet back on tell us what's
been going on where you are
well that's right Cyril just in the past
15 minutes the air raid sirens started
ringing out across the city of Kiev it's
the first air alert that we've had today
over the course of the past few days
many times throughout the early morning
hours uh throughout the the early
afternoon and sometimes even in the
evening the air raid sirens have rung
out because there were two consecutive
days of air strikes here you had drone
strikes on Monday you had missile
strikes that were hitting around the
area uh yesterday on on Tuesday we have
not had any reports as of yet of any
missiles targeting any specific areas or
any drones being spotted above and we've
not had any reports yet of the air
defense systems of Ukraine shooting down
any incoming objects that all being said
because of the strikes that I was just
telling you about that happened uh first
by the Kamikaze drones on Monday and
then by the missiles yesterday there
have been many power infrastructure
sites across the country and even close
to the Capitol that that have been hit
these past 48 hours because of that
there has been a great deal of concern
being expressed from Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski and many other
Ukrainian officials as to the fact that
so many critical infrastructure sites
have been damaged they're saying that at
least 30 percent of the country's power
stations have been hit since October
10th and because of that they are urging
citizens to start to try to conserve on
their power usage they're also saying
that there could be power blackouts
happening in the days and weeks to come
this is a big concern right now because
temperatures are dropping precipitously
as winter approaches now one of the
areas hit close to where we are
yesterday is the desnyansky district
that's east of the capital it's about 30
minutes away from where we are right now
in the center of Kiev we spent several
hours there yesterday when we were there
speaking to residents of an apartment
complex they were without water they
were without power it's the second time
it's happened to them in the last two
weeks and they were really worried about
what this bodes for them for the weeks
and months ahead since we spoke to them
we have been told that power in that
area and utilities have all come back
online and that's really the pattern
that we've been seeing a lot in the last
week in the areas that we visited when
there are strikes when power is offline
it doesn't seem to take too much time
before power is restored in those areas
that being said though there are still
areas of the country where power is out
and the concern right now is that there
will be more areas of the country where
power is out in the coming days weeks
and months if there are continued
Russian strikes this is what Ukrainian
officials have been saying zero all
right Muhammad reporting from Keith
thank you very much